Stakes are the reason that audience is
become invested in your story. Stakes
are the things that make an audience
worry or wonder, makes them curious,
makes them root for you, makes them hope
for your demise. Stakes are essential to
a story. They are the things that make
people want to hear the end of the
story. They're the things that drive
people to the end of the story. There
are several types of stakes that you can
deploy in a story and all can be very
powerful. The most important stake of
all is what I call the elephant.
I call it the elephant because it's
enormous. It's enormously important to a
story. The elephant is essentially the
initial signpost to the audience that
says, "This is what my story is about,
at least for now." In a movie, we don't
really need an elephant because what we
have today is movie trailers. When we go
into a movie, we kind of know what we're
going to see. If we're going into a
Mission Impossible movie, we know what
the stakes are. The world is in danger
and Tom Cruise must save the day. When
we walk into a romantic comedy, we know
what the stakes are, what the elephant
is. It is two people are not in love.
Will they be in love by the end of the
movie? Those are the stakes. But when
we're speaking, telling a story,
delivering a sales pitch, speaking at a
conference, delivering a keynote, nobody
knows really what we're going to say as
we open our mouths. We need to give them
a reason right away to be invested in
that story with what I call an elephant.
Standing in the playground behind my
school beside this enormous pile of
leaves and this tiny little hand comes
out of the leaves with a silver metallic
object in it. And the boy attached to
the hand, he says, "Look, Mr. Dix, a
spoon."
And it It's a spoon. It's a ordinary
kitchen spoon, probably fell out of a
lunchbox earlier that day or 10 years
ago.
But I say, "No, Jamie,
that's the spoon of power.
And now that I've declared it to be the
spoon of power, I must have it because
that is who I am."
And Jamie knows this. I can see it on
the look in his face and he knows that I
know it and I know that he knows that I
know it, and all of this is true cuz
he's running before he says anything
else. And the 74 kids that I'm supposed
to be monitoring closely are lost to me,
and the only thing I focus on is a
little red-headed boy with a spoon that
I must now have. And we run across the
field, and we climb up the slide and
through the tubes, and 17 minutes later
the bell rings, and that little boy
still has the spoon, and I can't believe
it. The spoon of power.
>> It's a very similar elephant at the
beginning. A spoon has made an
appearance in a little boy's hand, and
Matt must now have that spoon. Will he
get the spoon? That is the elephant that
I present at the beginning of the story.
It's actually the elephant or the steak
that carries us through much of the
story until he eventually puts it on a
chain around his neck, and then the
elephant changes.
>> It's
It's 1991, and I'm 20 years old, and I'm
driving home from the very first booty
call of my entire life, and I am excited
because I don't know that this is going
to also be the very last booty call of
my entire life.
And then it's in that moment of
excitement that the right front tire of
my 1976 Chevy Malibu blows out, but it
doesn't deflate, it disintegrates. It
throws rubber rubber on the road in a
way that I didn't think was possible,
and it takes everything I can to get the
car over to the shoulder and to a stop.
And it's 1991.
I don't have a cell phone, so I do the
only thing I can, I start hiking up the
road to look for help.
7 hours later,
after giving all of my money to a
half-naked mountain man named Winston, I
have a bald tire on my car, and I'm
heading home when I look at the
instrument panel, and I see that I have
no gas. And all of the money that I have
is in Winston's hand. And it's 1991. I
don't have a credit card, I don't have
an ATM card, I don't even have a
checking account.
And so I take the next exit and I roll
my car into a Getty station.
And as I park the car, I'm angry and I'm
sad. I'm 20 years old. I'm a McDonald's
manager. I'm making $7.25
an hour and I'm the richest person I
know.
My mother is living on welfare with my
sister.
My father's left 10 years ago and the
only friend that I have who even has a
credit card or a car that can make this
100-mile trip to New Hampshire is off on
some college weekend and I can't get in
touch with him. And this was not the
plan for my life. I was not supposed to
be this alone.
And so I go into the Getty station to
beg for gas. $8 worth of gas is all I
need cuz it's 1991 and gas is $0.85 a
gallon.
And the kid behind the counter will not
give it to me. He doesn't want to lose
his job and I offer everything and he
says no. So I go back to my car. My plan
is to wait for the next shift change.
Maybe someone more sympathetic will take
over. But as I climb into my car, I see
my McDonald's uniform crumpled in the
back and I have an idea. The initial
elephant, the question, the curiosity,
the reason you want to be driven home to
the end of the story is Matt has a flat
tire and he has no money. How will he
get home? That is the stake. That is the
elephant at the beginning of the story
that will grab your attention and cause
you to wonder, how will this problem be
solved? If you're a problem solver, the
kind of person that likes to puzzle
things out, you might have actually
started to think about solutions for me,
solutions on my behalf, something that
happened 30 years ago you're worried
about now and wondering how I was going
to get out of it. The goal of an
elephant is to give an audience a reason
to be immediately invested in the story.
How will Matt get out of New Hampshire?
An hour later, I'm in a residential
neighborhood about a mile from the Getty
station. I'm on the porch of a red brick
house and I'm knocking on the door. I'm
wearing my McDonald's uniform, the blue
shirt, the blue pants, the blue tie.
The door opens and there's a man
standing in front of me and I know at
that moment that this is a bad idea.
But it's 3:00 on a Sunday afternoon and
I'm on his porch in a McDonald's uniform
and the only way to get off is to go
forward. So I say to him,
"My name is Matt. I'm collecting money
for the Ronald McDonald Children's
Charities.
Can you please make a donation?"
And this man stares at me like
Stonehenge. He does not move. He's 50
but he might as well be 500. He has all
of the wisdom and knowledge of the world
wrapped into one man and I know he knows
I'm lying. And the next words that come
out of my mouth I don't expect. I say,
"My mom died of cancer when I was young
and my sister has cancer now and I'm
just trying to do what I can to help."
And he looks at me and points and says,
"You stay right there." And he goes back
into the house and closes the door and I
know that he's calling the police and
I'm going to get arrested for stealing
money from McDonald's which ironically 2
years later will actually happen.
But not on this day
because he comes back to the door and he
has $20 in his hand which is like
$20,000 to me on this day and he presses
it into my palm and I say, "No, that's
too much." And he says to me, "My wife
died of cancer 5 years ago."
And I think this is a really bad idea I
had and before I know it I am sitting on
the porch with this man and he asks me
what my mother died of and I say breast
cancer cuz it's the first one that pops
to my mind and he says, "What does your
sister have?" And I say leukemia which I
don't actually know is a cancer but I
know kids get it. And he tells me that
his wife Lisa died of lung cancer
and that his kids live on the West
Coast, and he tells me how she struggled
for 2 years, and how he wanted to tell
her it was okay to go, but he couldn't,
and how badly he felt that he watched
her struggle for so long. And I sat on
that porch, and I listened to him, and I
prayed he wouldn't ask me anything, and
I just wanted to get off.
And so finally we were hugging, and I
was walking down the walk with $20 in my
hand, and it felt like poison.
I got to my car, and I sat in there, and
I remembered how lonely I felt,
and then I felt so stupid and small.
Cuz I knew at that moment I didn't
understand real loneliness. I was a
20-year-old kid with friends, and I was
stuck in New Hampshire.
But I had walked away from a man who was
in a tiny house with a wife that was
gone, and the kids that were gone, and
he had a loneliness in him that I would
never understand.
And so I put the gas in my car, and I
drove home.
But he has always been with me.
I have never left that man on that porch
that day,
and I'm hopeful that I'll never be as
lonely as he was that day. Thank you.
>> I say that elephants can change their
color, meaning the primary stake of a
story, the primary reason we're invested
in a character, that can change over
time, as it did in the story you just
heard. The initial elephant is, will
Matt find a way to get out of New
Hampshire with no gas and no money?
Eventually that elephant changes colors.
When I end up on the porch in front of a
blue door with a man who's talking to me
about the death of his wife, it's no
longer a concern how I'm going to get
out of New Hampshire. That stake is now
gone. There's a new stake. How is Matt
going to deal with this situation? But
there has to be that elephant in a story
all the time. There has to be a reason
that the audience is invested in what is
happening to the character, the product,
the company, the CEO, whoever is
speaking, there has to be an elephant.
When Steve Jobs takes the stage and
says,
>> This is a day
I've been looking forward to for 2 and
1/2 years.
>> I have been waiting 2 and 1/2 years to
tell you this. That's the elephant. It
is, I have news that's going to blow you
away. I have been waiting a long time to
share this with you. That is the
elephant. We must open our stories with
an elephant. The other stakes I'm going
to discuss, they're all optional, but
this one is essential. We have to have
something to invest our audience in, to
make them feel like they are with us and
that they want to get to the end to find
out how things are going to turn out. We
open with an elephant, the first and
most important stake in every story we
tell.